comment déclare-t-on la guerre à un
virus ça c'est la grosse question vient
je crois que on peut appliquer un
certain nombre de principes de la
propagande de guerre au virus covit 19
que nous connaissons maintenant bien
c'est à dire que c'est un c'est lui qui
nous a déclaré la guerre c'est pas nous
nous voulons la paix nous sommes en
guerre lui c'est quelqu'un de monstrueux
qui commet des choses épouvantables et
qui utilisent des armes non autorisé
personne est invulnérable y compris les
plus jeunes alors que nous nous sommes
des gens absolument clean
nous ferons preuve de la même force
d'âme de la même abnégation patriotes
lui il essaie par des méthodes de ruses
de nous attaquer l'ennemi est là
invisible insaisissable qui progressent
alors ceux qui n'y croient pas parce que
ce sont des alliés objectifs du virus
[Musique]